este embalse es conocido como el mar de
Castilla el embalse de almendras una de
las más de 4.500 barreras fluviales que
bordean el duero entre España y Portugal
desde hace 44 años Arturo de Inés es
alcalde de un pueblo ribereño del
embalse este año vio la Cuenca casi
completamente seca
desde agosto y septiembre para acá ha
sido el año que más bajo hemos visto el
embalse el año que pasamos miedo cuando
nos quedábamos sin agua ahí se ve que el
brazo está medio enterrado en el agua
y que está subiendo el agua y que sin
embargo ahora pues está todo el brazo
descubierto
hace dos meses se enviaron 200 millones
de metros cúbicos de agua a Portugal
para cumplir el convenio de albufeira
este tratado firmado en 1998 obliga a
España río arriba de Portugal a
suministrar agua a su vecino cada año
una medida que preocupa a Arturo este en
base abastece de agua potable a un
centenar de municipios
que no dejar en agua no podíamos
consentirlo tuvimos que dar una caja la
de gobierno que nos escucharon y
prohibieron la salida esta comarca es de
la ganadería si la ganadería anota no la
podemos sostener que no tenemos agua nos
tenemos que barrear todos a ver qué
vamos a ver aquí en respuesta a las
sequía España ha reducido por primera
vez la cantidad de agua que envía a su
vecino portugués una decisión posible
gracias a la revisión del convenio en
kilómetros río arriba herminio Medina es
agricultor este año también ha estado
cerca del desastre
el 20% del suministro de agua de su
cooperativa estuvo a punto de ser
enviado a Portugal
esta remolacha viene consumiendo
alrededor para que sea una producción
buena viene consumiendo alrededor de
5500 metros cúbicos por hectárea
si esto estuviéramos consentido que
hubieran sacado el agua del trasvase
había que haberle dado 4.500 entraría en
muchas pérdidas a instancias de herminio
3000 agricultores se movilizaron contra
estos trasvases para este presidente de
una cooperativa agrícola Portugal no
haría buen uso de ella esto es una
concentración pacífica si nosotros
mandamos agua a Portugal León muere
León se seca
y ese agua solamente va dedicada a
turbinar y una vez de que turbinen el
agua va al mar pero en Portugal el duero
no solo se utiliza para producir energía
riega todo a una región que vive de la
agricultura en las mesetas de Miranda
todo uro Andrea cortiña cría un centenar
de ovejas
este año con la reducción de los
trasvases y la excepcional sequía tendrá
dificultades para alimentar a sus
animales mis ovejas sobaras están
comiendo más temprano la avena que
teníamos guardada para más adelante
cuando el invierno fuera más riguroso
pero tenemos que dar ya Porque no
tenemos el verde para Andrea esta
escasez ha tenido un costo los precios
del forraje que compras se han
triplicado en un año
pero reducir el caudal del duero también
tiene un impacto ecológico
Ana giraldez es científica controla la
calidad del agua contaminada por la
agricultura y la actividad humana en la
parte española
aquí estamos en el curso principal del
duero el agua que ves viene de España si
España reduce el caudal de agua que nos
envía esto tiene consecuencias sobre su
calidad pero menos agua significa una
mayor concentración de contaminantes
este verano los ecologistas pudieron
medir varias veces concentraciones de
fósforo y nitrógeno superiores a las
normales para Ana es urgente revisar el
convenio de albufeira
Aunque ambos países cumplen la directiva
europea del agua no han unificado su
gestión del duero
no es en absoluto lógico que Portugal
tenga un plan de gestión del río duero
diferente al de España
creó es esencial que la gestión del río
se armonice River
España y Portugal se reunieron A
mediados de diciembre en Lisboa se
comprometieron a armonizar sus
indicaciones de sequía para reforzar la
gestión conjunta de los cinco ríos que
comparten